Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Mon intérêt pour la mobilité
des marchandises
s’est déclarée dans le chocolat.
De 2006 à 2014,
j’ai participé à un déploiement
d’une chocolaterie
au début artisanale, bio, commerce
équitable, qui s’appelle Belvas.
Cette chocolaterie,
on la voulait parfaite -
on choisissait les meilleurs ingrédients,
mais on voulait aussi avoir l’impact
environnemental le plus faible possible.
On a énormément travaillé
à différentes choses,
jusqu’à même récupérer la chaleur de l’air
conditionné pour faire fondre le chocolat.
Ces efforts ont été récompensés :
la chocolaterie Belvas
a été élue à l’époque
la micro-entreprise
la plus écologique d’Europe.
Super, mais je me suis rendu
compte d’une chose :
il y avait un facteur sur lequel
nous n’avions pas d’emprise.
La mobilité.
Chacun venait à la chocolaterie - chacun
des chocolatiers, des collègues -
avec sa propre voiture.
Une autre mobilité qui posait problème,
c’était la mobilité des marchandises.
Impossible de l’organiser de manière
optimale, ça ne dépendait plus de nous.
Lorsque j’ai quitté la chocolaterie
Belvas, c’est un article
que ma partenaire m’a glissé
sous les yeux qui a créé le déclic,
qui a créé l’envie de changer les choses
en termes de mobilité des marchandises.
City Dépôt était alors actif à Hasselt
dans le développement d’une mobilité
des marchandises intelligentes,
une façon de revoir un peu les choses.
J’ai contacté le porteur du projet
et quelques mois plus tard,
j’ouvrais le premier centre de
distribution urbain de Bruxelles.
Un CDU.
Qu’est-ce qu’un CDU ?
Un CDU, c’est une plateforme logistique
que l’on place à l’entrée d’une ville
qui va collecter les flux de marchandises,
les réorganiser, les combiner
de façon à ce que les transports en ville
soient beaucoup plus efficaces.
Avant, les magasins jouaient
le rôle de petits stocks dans la ville
auprès desquels vous et moi, les
consommateurs allions nous approvisionner.
Maintenant, de plus en plus,
on achète en ligne -
on va chercher dans
un stock en dehors de la ville,
voire en dehors du pays, avec un flux
qui va venir jusque chez nous.
Donc, les flux sont démultipliés
et complexifiés au maximum.
La ville, c’est comme une maison :
on n’y entre pas avec ses bottines
pleines de boue.
On va les enlever et on va mettre des
chaussures d’intérieur quand on rentre.
Le CDU, c’est comparable à un vestiaire,
un endroit où on va pouvoir,
en tant que transporteur,
changer de mode de transport
pour s’adapter à la zone
vers laquelle on doit livrer.
Le problème, c’est que le fait de
s’arrêter, de s’asseoir sur le petit banc,
d’enlever ses chaussures, ça prend
du temps, ça perd de l’efficacité,
ça coûte de l’argent.
C’est ce qu’on appelle dans
le jargon la rupture de charge.
La rupture de charge fait
en sorte que finalement,
les transporteurs, tout le monde,
on rentre avec nos bottines
bien boueuses dans la maison.
Comment faire en sorte que,
finalement, on utilise ce CDU ?
Comment faire en sorte
qu’on organise tout cela ?
Il y a deux choses.
La première : il faut des règles,
des règles claires et appliquées.
Et ça, c’est le rôle des pouvoirs publics.
Ils doivent décider,
à l’entrée de la maison,
qui rentre, qui ne rentre pas et comment.
Évidemment qu’un semi-remorque
de 33 palettes
qui va livrer une seule destination
ne va pas se décharger
complètement à l’entrée de la maison
pour repartir avec 33 petits camions,
non, non.
Ce semi-remorque, il vaudrait mieux
qu’il livre le soir ou la nuit,
et de préférence en silence.
Mais par contre, tous les flux
qui ne sont pas structurés,
qui ne sont pas encore combinés,
devraient passer par le CDU.
Des règles, donc.
Deuxième chose qu’il faudrait :
c’est une infrastructure.
Il faut mailler la région, la ville,
de deux types d’emplacements logistiques.
D’une part, des grands hubs comme le CDU
qu’on va mettre à l’extérieur de la ville
et qui vont réceptionner les gros camions.
Et des plus petits hubs dans les centres
urbains, dans les centres historiques,
des endroits plus compliqués d’accès.
Il faut combiner ces deux
types d’infrastructures.
Il faut permettre la multimodalité.
Si on peut, et c’est encore mieux, il
faudrait connecter ça à l’eau, au rail.
Et cette infrastructure doit faciliter les
interactions entre les différents acteurs
qui eux-mêmes utilisent
différents types de marchandises.
J’ai quitté City Dépôt
avec
un regret :
c’est que le vélo ne jouait pas son rôle
dans la logistique des marchandises.
Or, théoriquement, une étude européenne
de 2017 l’atteste - de Cyclelogistics.
Elle a analysé plusieurs grandes
villes européennes et elle a affirmé
que minimum 25 % - voire jusque
parfois 50 %, selon les marchandises -
minimum 25 % des marchandises
sont transportables à vélo.
Une livraison sur quatre devrait
pouvoir se faire à vélo.
Or à l’époque, à Bruxelles,
on en comptait quoi ?
Une sur mille.
Comment expliquer que le vélo-cargo,
qui pourtant existe,
ne réalise pas son plein potentiel ?
Deux raisons.
La première, c’est que le monde
de la cyclo-logistique,
donc la logistique à vélo, est très mal,
ou très peu, connecté
aux standards
de la logistique internationale.
Ce qui fait qu’on va devoir,
[pour transférer] des marchandises
d’un camion dans un vélo.
les retrier, les remanipuler,
et ça va coûter beaucoup d’argent.
Ça va rendre cette rupture
de charge dont on parlait
encore plus chère, encore plus lourde,
et donc ça ne marche pas.
La deuxième raison pour laquelle le vélo
est sous-utilisé en logistique,
c’est le fait
que les externalités positives du vélo ne
sont pas prises en compte - je m’explique.
Il y a une autre étude -
Jochen Maes, Universiteit Antwerp -
en 2017, qui a valorisé ces externalités,
qui a simplement collé un chiffre en euros
à côté de chacune des externalités,
que ce soit la santé,
que ce soit pour la mobilité,
que ce soit pour la qualité de l’air,
l’écologie,
pour le bien que
ça ferait pour la collectivité
par rapport à ce que fait une camionnette.
Une fois qu’il a réussi à intégrer
tous ces chiffres,
dans les coûts du vélo par rapport
aux coûts de la camionnette,
ça y est, le vélo est plus efficace,
le vélo est plus rentable
que la camionnette.
Il faudrait prendre en compte
les externalités positives du vélo
pour permettre la logistique du vélo,
en tout cas, lui permettre d’atteindre
tout son [potentiel].
En 2017 toujours, je fais une rencontre
vraiment très spéciale.
Charles Levillain a développé
la remorque BicyLift.
C’est une remorque qui permet de soulever
puis de transporter une europalette,
ou tout autre contenant
de la même taille que l’europalette,
à vélo pour partir et livrer jusqu’à
200 kilos de marchandises en une fois.
C'est une révolution pour moi.
Et c’est sur la base de cette invention
qu’avec mes collègues Renaud et Delphine,
nous nous lançons dans une grande aventure
avec l’envie de concrétiser ce potentiel
du vélo-cargo pour la logistique.
Nous créons Urbike.
Urbike se base sur trois innovations.
La première, c’est cette remorque,
cette BicyLift, qui permet de transporter
des conteneurs, comme je le disais -
le conteneur rappelle
évidemment le conteneur maritime,
cette invention du début
du siècle précédent
permettant de transporter
tout type de marchandises,
qui facilitait la connexion entre
les différents types de transports,
le bateau vers le train,
le train vers le camion.
C’est le conteneur avec ses
dimensions classiques, cette bête boîte,
qui a permis l’essor
des échanges internationaux.
Faisons la même chose
au niveau de la ville.
Le conteneur urbain, de la taille
d’une europalette, n’invente rien,
mais permet simplement
de réduire drastiquement
les coûts de cette satanée
rupture de charge.
La deuxième innovation sur laquelle
s’appuie Urbike, elle est technologique.
Il faut optimiser les courses,
il faut automatiser tous les process,
limiter ce qui est administratif,
ce qui n’a pas de valeur ajoutée.
Il faut informer en temps réel le client
de l’endroit où se trouvent
ses marchandises,
de l’état de chacune de ses livraisons.
On s’est inspiré de l’économie
de plateforme finalement,
qui connecte directement
le donneur d’ordres
au coursier qui va réaliser la course.
Mais par contre,
notre troisième innovation,
c’est le modèle économique.
Là, on s’éloigne un peu du concept
de l’économie de plateforme.
C’est-à-dire qu’avant tout,
notre volonté, c’est de revaloriser
le métier de coursier à vélo.
On crée un job sûr, de qualité,
source de fierté,
mais également c’est une coopérative
d’économie sociale,
c’est-à-dire que la recherche
du profit n’est pas notre objectif.
Nous allons autant valoriser les impacts
écologiques et sociaux
que les impacts économiques.
Urbike est né il y a trois ans.
On a commencé les opérations
il y a un an et demi.
On est soutenu par près
de 300 citoyens coopérateurs
qui ont investi leur argent
dans ce projet.
On a une incroyable équipe
de 35 personnes, trois hubs à Bruxelles.
On livre 20 000 colis par mois.
C’est l’équivalent de 100
tonnes de marchandises
qui ne sont plus transportées par des
petits camions ou par des camionnettes.
On a encore de beaux jours
devant nous parce que
les clients sont de plus
en plus convaincus.
Et ce sera ma conclusion.
C’est ce qui me rend heureux,
c’est ce changement de mentalité.
Je l’espère, je l’attends depuis
que je parle de City dépôt,
depuis que je me suis intéressé
à la mobilité des marchandises.
Maintenant, j’ai l’impression
que ça prend, que,
même au niveau des grands transporteurs,
des professionnels
du secteur de la logistique,
il y a une compréhension, une prise
de conscience du rôle réel et efficace
que le vélo peut prendre dans la
mobilité des marchandises en ville,
dans ce qu’on appelle le last mile.
Il faut maintenant développer
ce modèle d’économie sociale
et le répliquer dans le plus
de villes possible.
Et là, on aura un double effet : on aura
des villes beaucoup plus agréables
et on pourra créer des centaines, des
milliers d’emplois de qualité et durables.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)